there's a new uh sort of um enlightened
centrist hot take which is okay
biden's doing well on vaccinations now
but it's all built on the system that
donald trump and his administration
built
and that couldn't be further from the
truth
there's a good article in talking points
memo
by kate rega and josh kavinsky which
says
you know the washington post is doing
this the new york times is doing this
they're saying
that the speed up we are seeing now
builds on the trump plan and it is
simply wrong
kate and josh do a deep dive into what
was actually happening in the trump
administration during the last few
months
and in fact it's stunning at how well
joe biden has been able to expand
vaccination
despite donald trump's actions there was
no plan left behind
biden and his team had to build the plan
from day one
for how to get the vaccines once they
were dumped at states
to places that are actually vaccinating
established vaccination sites and the
like
uh there even when given the opportunity
on supply
joe biden has had to fix the problems
that donald trump left behind
including trump famously turning down
100 million doses of pfizer back in july
of 2020
maybe because pfizer wasn't
participating in operation warp speed
that left joe biden to figure out how
can we actually get enough vaccines for
people and now we will have enough
vaccines where on may 1st we will be
opening
eligibility to everybody 18 plus in the
united states
every aspect of what donald trump did
was counterproductive other than
what we could say here's the praise we
could give of donald trump
beyond all the things he did to stifle
us having enough vaccines and reduce
interest in vaccination
trump didn't actively deny funding
to companies developing vaccines and
that's barely praise
and i know that one of the things you
heard
there were two things that were
repeatedly mentioned during the trump
era that trump was doing one is
he's funding vaccine research just about
every country was funding vaccine
research
in the middle of a global pandemic what
government wouldn't
fund research to some degree to say that
trump deserves
praise for that if he didn't do it it
would have been criminal now many of the
companies researching vaccines didn't
take the money
or they didn't need the money but to say
trump funded stuff i mean listen the
government funds
endless things and to say that's why he
gets credit
is very low now the other thing is you
know trump tells the story of how
they came to me they said sir let's
fund manufacture of vaccines
even before we know these vaccines are
going to be effective and the ones to
use
this has been widely done across the
world
for decades when you have an urgent
situation and you have
a vaccine or a medication that looks
like it will work but it's still being
tested
you don't want to waste time you want
doses ready to go
if and when it gets approved so what you
do is you manufacture vaccines
on spec you start manufacturing a bunch
of different candidates
so that if they get approved you already
have some doses
trump did fund that i guess he gets
credit for that now what about on the
other side what did he do
to hurt the vaccine effort well number
one when you say it's not serious for a
year
and that it's being exaggerated by the
left and that all aspects of this start
to take away your freedom and all of
this stuff
that reduces people's interest in
getting vaccinated because why would i
get vaccinated for something my dear
leader trump has been telling me isn't
serious
for a year number two trump's own
vaccination
happened while he was still in office in
secret and we only learned about it in
the last week or so
because it leaked that is not something
you do if you're trying to get more
people interested in getting the vaccine
number three trump declined doses when
they were
offered by pfizer in july of 2020 as i
mentioned
again maybe mad because they weren't
part of operation warp speed
and it left us with a a need
for joe biden to figure out where to get
more doses so
i'm sorry guys trump doesn't deserve
credit for vaccines
trump was to some degree
just not a factor in that he allowed
money to go
towards some vaccine research and did
some things that decreased interest in
the vaccine
and handed off no plan to joe biden he
he could have more aggressively hurt the
cause
but trump doesn't deserve credit for
these vaccines and what we are seeing
now in terms of the rollout in the
expansion
was a plan that joe biden started
building in december
knowing what he was coming into and and
joe biden
has not joe biden there's lots of things
he doesn't deserve praise for right now
which i've criticized him for
this is joe biden's thing he put in
place a parallel coronavirus task force
back in december
they started figuring this out when they
took over there was no plan
they built the plan they secured doses
from a jnj
they got additional doses lined up from
modern up from pfizer
this really is biden's thing and it
seems pretty clear that
uh voters realize that but for some
reason
dr anthony fauci is baffled by what's
going on and i want to talk about that
next one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service
at privacy.com pacman i've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you
give each company a randomized virtual
credit card number that you create out
of thin air it'll even autofill the card
number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at slash privacy.com